Let's face it: It's always satisfying
to watch "Stranger Things" baddies get
what's coming to 'em. As far
as Season 4 goes, it seems as
if the death of one antagonist
was foreshadowed very early on.
After Vecna, Jason Carver could be considered the
next major "Stranger Things" Season 4 antagonist.
As the captain of the Hawkins High School
basketball team, Jason is popular enough
to command most of his teammates on and off the
court, leading them on a witch hunt for Eddie,
whom he believes is responsible for his
girlfriend's death at the end of Episode 1.
Before this, however, he and
the team celebrate winning the
championship game by drinking at Benny's
now-abandoned restaurant. The next morning,
Jason describes being hungover
as like being split in two.
"First hangover feels like
you're gonna split in two."
In fact, this is exactly what happens to him after
Vecna shatters the boundary between this world
and the Upside Down, essentially cleaving
Jason right down the middle. In the end,
he knows full well what being
split in two really feels like.